sometimes people will ask me what i call
myself am i a stunt man am i a comedian
am i an author an actor and you know
what i am i'm an attention [ __ ]
hey gq i'm stevo and these are my
absolute essentials let's get into it
[Music]
i'm a real road warrior so
i go everywhere
with everything i need
and this carry-on
luggage
[Applause]
i could very easily replace but what i
cannot replace and i cannot live without
is this back scratcher
i got it at whole foods in maybe 2009 my
body's generally becoming decrepit so i
can't reach areas where i have itches
and then the back scratcher is just
super important to me i could never
replace it
it's the greatest back scratcher of all
time out of fear that i may lose it i've
tried to replace it and there just isn't
one out there that can do the trick
my travel water pick
for all my years of hardcore partying
and drug abuse i never took care of my
teeth and gums and i ended up with all
kinds of problems there was a time when
i got in the jackass van and we man said
oh dude [ __ ] stevo your breath and
knoxville said
saying stevo has bad breath is like
saying we man is short
so this thing
is absolutely crucial
here's how it works
[Music]
[Music]
it blasts all this stuff out from in
between your teeth which would go rotten
and stink
so i count my water pick as toiletries
which are very important to me i've got
my toiletry kit right here and when i
check into a hotel room on the road i
then take a picture of my wiener in the
mirror with the toiletries and i send it
to my girl and among my toiletries i
have an absolute essential in my hill
planner
it's called zoloft man
[Music]
i went to therapy
back in 2013 and this therapist was
telling me that he feels that i have
like a lot of anxiety and that zoloft
would help me and i'm like dude i'm a
clean and sober guy you know i don't
take drugs turned out the therapist was
a clean and sober guy too and i just
decided to humor him i've since found
that zoloft really helps me if i stop
taking it my mind can go to super dark
places if i am taking it like
full steam ahead baby
[Music]
gonna have my speakers you know it
because i got a rock i'm not gonna count
these speakers as essential because
they're so replaceable but i do love
them because they've got these marks
when i would do meet and greets after my
shows on tour i pull out a marker to
sign stuff and i would push it in
jam it on there so every one of these
dots represents a different show on tour
you know i i will count the speakers as
essential but they're just not that sexy
what second
what i really think is essential is the
markers i travel with
markers are totally essential to me you
know i'm big into signing my merch i'm
ready to do it with white paint pen
with black marker with silver
i'm so proud of my autograph i practiced
my autograph for years before anybody
wanted it and after signing it for the
longest time all of a sudden i realized
that when i write my signature i'm
actually drawing a penis i mean it's
fascinating i gotta show it i gotta show
you got a piece of paper
[Music]
yeah and if it's a really important
autograph then i'll do hashtag
dickograph
this is for you guys
i'm an attention [ __ ] and i gotta be
ready to film attention seeking behavior
at all times
that's three different
4k cameras and i'm ready to load up
big memory cards and then back it up on
the hard drive
and then in virtually real time
edit it on the computer
two really killer
what i operate with is a full-blown
studio in my backpack
safe to say that camera stores are my
happy place just had a really great
experience at a camera store in
washington dc on the same day that i got
arrested for climbing on the lincoln
memorial
[Music]
years ago my tour manager said you
should come out with your own hot sauce
because you just love hot sauce so much
and i was kind of resistant to it but
then we decided to give it a shot and we
came up with stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
we tried all different recipes and
combined multiple ones of them there was
the xxx habanero i really liked but also
the habanero garlic
they had to go together so
technically i'm a chef the other flavor
that we just came out with which is
called stevo's butthole destroyer hot
sauce the top three ingredients are the
three hottest peppers in the world
scorpion
ghost and carolina reaper so that's
what's filling up the bottle
but people are buying it
[Music]
candidly my diet's kind of all over the
place being sensitive to my nutrition
needs i'm counting this as totally
essential
it's called
athletic greens ag-1 this is how i start
every day i meditate in the morning i
get water to hydrate and i pour into the
water my athletic grains ag-1 and it's
great because i can do it on an empty
stomach it gives me all the nutrition i
need i can feel good about eating like a
jerk for the rest of the day and it's
actually delicious too
and they're not paying me to say that
right now so when i finish my athletic
greens in the morning now i'm hydrated
and i feel good about just pounding
coffee so i fill up this 24 ounce
thermos
[Music]
oh man this is up there on the
essentials dude plus this one in
particular i've managed to not lose
through months of touring what i love
about it so much is that it's got this
button which is like a trigger you know
it's not gonna spill
unless you pull the trigger
so that's nine and now it comes down to
the most magical essential of them all
when
my wonderful wendy from peru i actually
found her in the streets of peru the
video i made of bringing wendy home from
peru got more views than any video i've
ever put on the internet that's a real
kick in the nuts but
she comes with me everywhere she's a
bona fide legit service dog she's with
me on every airplane she's with me on
every tour date she actually performs in
my show
i mean she's just a phenomenal dog i
mean she's extraordinary she's a belgian
malinois and evidently xanax mix
so there we have it folks i cannot live
without these items and your attention
means the world to me so thank you for
watching and man
take care of the ones you love dudes
[Laughter]
[Applause]